guess where we're going to malaysia
we're going crazy you're not going to
believe this
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to appreciate and discover
every single historically significant
hamburger out there no matter how
bizarre
or unfamiliar it might be and all of
that applies to this burger
this is the rameli burger also known as
the malaysian burger
the sloppy burger the sampa burger which
is
actually malaysian for rubbish it's not
a rubbish burger at all though it's a
great burger
it's one of the craziest burgers i've
ever had it's a street burger wrapped in
an egg
sharp it's just wow that's like [ __ ]
great did i cut myself
safety first people safety first this
burger was born
on the streets of malaysia the same
exact year that
coincidentally mcdonald's opened its
first location in kuala lumpur i can
almost
imagine there are people who are there
are thinking themselves
that's it this is only beef and cheese
and bread
we want more and that's where this thing
comes in let's do this
now you're probably looking over here
going george what the hell are you doing
there's a lot of [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] table sorry i'm just trying to
say
one of the secrets of southeast asian
cooking is this beautiful stuff called
maggi
apparently if you're not putting this
seasoning on a malaysian street burger
you're not really making a malaysian
street burger you have to put this
evening called maggie
what's maggie it's actually hydrolyzed
soy protein
it is from of all places switzerland was
invented in
the 1880s in switzerland and somehow it
made its way to southeast asia where it
shows up in a lot of cooking
you're about to see something that's
very complicated now i hope i can do it
i'll tell you right now because i've
actually failed a few times with this
this is not it's not an easy burger and
i'm hungry
first thing we want to do is obviously
toast our buns no
not butter this is margarine and again
the beef
and the bun is almost inconsequential
they don't
those are just supporting actors i mean
the bun is the envelope for the good
news that's coming
and the beef is just there because well
otherwise you won't be able to call it a
burger
i'm gonna do a hand smash one of my
favorite ways to make a burger is to
hand smash you've seen this before
[Music]
from what i understand from a friend of
mine who's malaysian
tyson ho he told me that if you're using
like really great ingredients you just
didn't get it right
so the hallmark of a great ramney burger
is the most
industrial gmo trans fat filled
margarine
you could possibly buy this is a very
inexpensive burger
if you buy one on the street in kuala
lumpur
the egg wrap burger only costs about
1.50
u.s if you want to get a double it's two
dollars
and now we got a fire truck don't buy go
get em boys
didn't have a burger pop-up and um this
fire this fireman came by there was a
firehouse next to the pop-up
and he said uh hey can we get a 22
burgers
like what i think we'll pay for him and
all of a sudden i heard
and the truck comes out of the out of
the house he's they're racing off to a
fire
slams his brakes on right in front of me
he goes we'll catch you next time
[Laughter]
during quarantine it's very very
difficult to get burgers out to the
people
so i came up with a method i innovated i
came up with a burger slide
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay to this burger right now
throw some spice on
[Music]
every burger stall in malaysia has its
own proprietary blend of spices
this is spice that has curry garlic
powder onion powder
some cumin burgers pushed aside
good the egg here we go this is the part
that i may not get right
just so you know so again more margarine
and the egg here we go
i'm gonna do it the way that you would
actually look like this thing like this
they open up and then they have to do
this
they actually spread it out like they're
painting almost did i get it right
didn't get it right
damn it hang on i could do it again i
[ __ ] up i thought i knew it was gonna
happen
it's one of the hardest parts i think of
making this burger
you watch the guys do it in these videos
and i guess if you're on the street in
malaysia
and they make it look so easy i'm gonna
get this one okay what they do they take
the edge of the edge of the
sword edge of the sword edge of the
spatula
and then crack it there you go
it's almost like we're painting this
thing into a circle yeah
okay in this pile goes a slice of
american cheese yes
american cheese they have something that
looks like american cheese
put the patty on top of the cheese put
this right on top there
they have this amazing chili sauce i
would describe this
as being sort of a cross between say
duck sauce
and sriracha if you mix those two
together it's sweet
it's deadly spicy this thing should be
on hot ones chewy mayo
on top of that got a little more of the
spice right
splash of maggie not much a splash of
worcestershire on top of that
get this thing folded up
like a cool little package this is the
part that i couldn't understand but i
think i kind of got it
they take this thing and they kind of
flip it over like that hey i did it
see that gets flipped over and now we
basically have this perfect little egg
package here that's full of
all kinds of cool spices and that goes
on to
the bun now they also do is they put
more of the sauce on top
i'll do that as well now this is going
to be
it's already so freaking hot there it is
the malaysian burger
also known as the sampa or the sloppy
burger it's a pretty sloppy burger when
you eat this thing like i'm about to
right now
it gets everywhere
oh
wow that was a spicy
spicy looks like doesn't know if it
wants to be breakfast
or dinner or lunch whoa
i picked up i picked up the burger
there's an absolute beloved expression
of the hamburger
in southeast asia whoops it's all gone
now isn't it sorry
um see you next time
when i eat my next burger who knows what
we'll do
who knows what we'll do